answers the question should you stare at
the Sun by now it's been pretty well
established that you should never look
directly at the Sun you'll risk
permanent eye damage if you look at the
Sun without proper eye protection peer
through a dark beer bottle wrong
spray-paint glass don't do it never ever
do not look at the Sun like this you're
not supposed to stare right at the Sun
unless you hate your eyes it is gonna
cause significant damage to your eye
according to my optometrist do not stare
at the Sun obviously do not stare at the
Sun don't stare at the Sun don't stare
at the Sun do not look at the Sun is
everything we've been talking about for
like a year about this eclipse
you're gonna look straight into the Sun
yeah I'm afraid I am regret that
especially when it comes at the end of a
montage where they make local news
always so goofy guys remember bundle up
when it's cold out we've all got the
message do not stare at the Sun that is
from John Oliver's last week tonight we
welcome you back to CBS this morning
charlie's off but guess what bill we're
still here we didn't chase you off you
stayed around half an hour people who
see the total solar eclipse are sure to
be amazed but scientists say that the
animals may be confused when it gets
dark in the middle a day studies of
other eclipses found that birds can't
stop singing or even fought birds rather
birds can stop singing is what she's
trying to say or sometimes even follow
the ground
yikes bees could return to their hives
thinking that it's nighttime and spiders
may take down their way yeah South
Carolina is the last state in the
eclipses path before it moves over the
Atlantic Ocean Charleston is that
state's biggest city and it's packed
with people eager to see the Sun go dark
some of them will watch from boats along
the coast and that's where we find our
mark Strassmann mark good morning good
morning tens of thousands of sky
watchers have arrived by air by land and
by sea here in Charleston and the
boaters like everyone else are a little
bit nervous about the forecast clear
skies are key to watching this Eclipse
but the National Weather Service is
calling for potential trouble
thunderstorms may be
afternoon a 40% chance of rain a 50%
chance of cloud cover nevertheless
thousands of people will try to watch
this once-in-a-lifetime event from their
boats the Coast Guard will be on patrol
here to make sure those boaters do it
smartly and we talked to one Coast Guard
member about what to expect we want to
make sure people are aware be prepared
even if you're looking at the Eclipse
you need to be in control of your boat
so you can't look at the Eclipse and
have a proper lookout make sure you have
someone standing by if you want to take
that once-in-a-lifetime viewing
experience people here are hoping to see
the full power and effect of the Eclipse
at 2:47 Eastern Time this afternoon
totality will last about a minute and a
half here before this eclipse heads out
into the Atlantic Gale all right thank
you very much mark